Cory I know as we were setting up for
the interview you mentioned about the
last three years being much different in
terms of screenwriting and getting out
there right you talked about some of
those changes you're the currency's yeah
and especially in TV writing where a lot
of the action is so if you go back 10 or
15 years and you ask yourself of all the
scripts that are sold let's put them
into three different categories we have
paradigm driven scripts we could also
call these formula driven rules driven
so these are scripts where like if you
watch a bunch of three camera comedies
it's the same story structure just
different jokes or you watch a bunch of
superhero movies over the summer it's
kind of the same story beats are happy
at the same time so these are formula or
paradigm driven scripts so that's one
category of scripts that people can
write and try to sell then there's
imitative scripts so when Breaking Bad
Rose the phenomenal hit everyone was
writing their version of Breaking Bad or
people would write their version of
Arrested Development so you'd read
someone's script and you'd be like oh
this is like Mad Men but kind of
different and then the third kind of
script is pitch perfect authentic and so
that would be a script that like when
you read the pilot script for orange as
a new black it's not like anything
you've ever seen it's like orange is the
new black love it like it hate it it's
completely original we've never seen
these characters we've never seen this
world and the story is not formulaic it
doesn't hit these preordained plot
points
it's unfolds in the way that's most
compelling for what Jenji Kohan the
writer is trying to communicate Mad
Ben's another example community Sopranos
we could just go on and on moonlight so
these are scripts that don't follow a
paradigm they don't imitate what
somebody else did they're a wholly
original piece of work
original characters story and way of
telling that story so if we go back 12
or 15 years on the TV market who's
buying pitch-perfect authentic scripts
HBO Showtime that's it everyone else is
basically buying paradigm driven shows
genre driven shows or a show that
imitates a successful show so if you
to break in the business 10 years ago
even seven years ago you might follow a
formula you might follow a paradigm also
you're looking to get staffed on a TV
show so TV shows hire lots of writers so
if you want to be a comedy writer you
might write an episode of jane the
virgin or episode of silicon valley
you're a drama writer you'd write a
version of a drama to prove that you
could imitate a show everything's
completely different now so now when you
ask yourself who's buying pitch-perfect
authentic scripts HBO Showtime Netflix
Amazon AMC FX and the network's
basically everybody and the reason is
they're all chasing the key demographic
which is 18 to 49 and our generation
we've grown up on on-demand video demand
platforms so we've seen so many movies
we've seen so many TV shows we know
what's original and we know what is
imitative and by and large our
generation doesn't watch formula and so
basically the the key demographic wants
something that's original want something
that's new and different and there's so
much you can watch on TV it really needs
to be special to grab your attention and
so you to be loyal so people are loyal
transparent they're loyal to Game of
Thrones they're loyal to Jane the Virgin
and these are pitch perfect authentic
shows so I've read every script that is
sold in the last three years and the
vast majority are pitch perfect
authentic scrubs now there are paradigm
driven scripts that sell their our
imitative scripts that sell but the
people who sell those are people who
have a real serious track record in that
genre and what agents will always tell
my classes is if you have a standard
follow the dots comedy or drama or
procedural unless you've been an
executive producer or above on a hit
show in that space in the last three
years your scripts dead on arrival no
one will even read the script
further showrunners now when they staff
shows they won't look at imitation
scripts they don't want to look at your
version of a show they want to read a
pitch-perfect original script
and what they always tell my classes is
if you can write to a show if you can
imitate my voice if you can follow a
paradigm or a formula that doesn't mean
you're a great writer if you're an
amazingly great writer you can eat my
voice you can follow how I tell my
stories so it's really heartbreaking
because there's so many books and
classes and seminars that probably made
a lot of sense five years ago that are
teaching people these paradigms or
teaching people how to imitate and a set
of rules that no longer applies so it's
like writers are being trained for a war
that doesn't exist anymore and just real
quick in features if you're going to
work for the studio's you are going to
be doing a Pixar film a Star Wars film
or a Marvel action film that's basically
your three choices and they Pixar has a
way they tell their stories Marvel has
the way they tell their story Star Wars
has a way to tell their stories but I
have students I just have a student
who's got her first writing job at Pixar
but the script that she wrote was a
pitch perfect authentic script so even
though when they hire her they're gonna
expect her to write a Pixar script you
don't break in with a Pixar script you
don't break in imitating or following a
formula you break in with a script that
when everyone reads it they go holy moly
who wrote this this is amazing this
writer I have to meet this writer I have
to be in business with those writers so
when you look at the writers who are
writing all the features for the
studio's they either have amazing track
record of credits like Lawrence Kasdan
or they wrote an amazing pitch perfect
authentic script that no one had seen
before blew people away and then
Marvel's like hey would you be
interested in doing our you know
whatever movie we're making and yes at
that point when you got hired you're
certainly going to write it the way
Marvel wants you to write it but the
mistake I see as so many writers write
their superhero scripts or their paint
by the number of scripts and they can't
figure out why they can't get a career
they're just simply writing the wrong
kinds of scrubs